welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul AKA not your average Joel
in this video we're breaking down The
Last of Us episode 2. The Series has had
two really good episodes back to back
and is a big fan of the game I've loved
watching these first two entries They do
change some things up though and
throughout the video we're going to be
going over the Easter eggs game
differences and also giving our thoughts
on the series so far huge thank you to
everyone who watched our video last week
and like that one we're gonna be saving
the most spoilery Easter eggs until the
end so that people who haven't played
the game can enjoy the twists and turns
that come up in the show I'll give you a
heads up before we hit that and we start
the episode off in Jakarta all the way
back in 2003. if you cast your mind back
to last week then you may remember that
they did an announcement over the radio
that talked about the city and how
summing strangers going on there here we
see it playing out with the outbreak of
the infection being studied by a doctor
this wasn't in the game and I like how
the series is slowly filling in the
backstory of the virus both the
beginning of the last episode and this
one had completely new bits in them and
it's possible that we might even get a
story slotted in at the opening of each
entry that gives us way more details on
the infection than what we ever got in
the game now when the title cards were
shown we can see this is taking place on
September 24 2003 dating it two days
before the outbreak this of course shows
how fast the virus spread and in the
game we learn it was through products
containing flower and yeast which we'll
talk more about in just a bit huge [__]
out to Dynamic Smurf on our last video
for pointing out that 2003 was
potentially chosen because it was one of
the hottest years on records with a
record-breaking Heat Wave happening that
killed 20 000 people the subtitles used
throughout this part of the show also
highly resemble the captions from the
game missing is more in The Last of Us
world we start off with a sunny
seemingly normal day in Indonesia which
is when the military arrive and summon
the scientists to a lab though the world
is stabilized The Last of Us storylines
filled with different militant factions
throughout that all try to seize power
to impose their rule bedro were of
course a big part of these and I love
how in the backdrop there's all always
the idea of US versus them this is
echoed and Abu who's pretty fearful that
she's been taken in she suspects they
think she's committed a crime but they
want it because she's a professor in
mycology mycology is the study of fungi
and she's the top scientist in the
country after having graduated from the
University of Indonesia IBU is escorted
Pastor reception desk and this actually
leaked online when the show was in
production she walks past several
vaccine advertisements as well and these
are all riffing on the week into a
poster he once more get it ham at home
that there's no cure and this is why
Ellie's such a Paramount person in the
story now boo Ratner then examines the
specimen and he's taken to one of the
infected that we can't show can't show
it trust bloody HBO to have a fully nude
woman they can't bloody help themselves
now the woman has a bullet hole in her
head and she clearly only stopped once
she was shot around her but we see a
bite mark and upon being opened up this
spreads out like the ones from Mrs
Adler's mouth last week in a mouth era
cordyceps as well and that's a really
creepy Dimension to the entire thing now
I didn't want to bring up the clickers
last week as it could have spoiled some
stuff for people who didn't want to know
but we finally get to meet some in this
episode they don't disappoint either and
through their biology we can see how the
cordyceps work they basically infect a
person and then they spread through
their body slowly replacing their cells
with fungi so they very much become
almost like a living mushroom a man
Toadstool from Mario he ain't got [__]
on these and the fungus eventually
completely devours their brain and the
upper part of their head this makes them
blind and it's why the clickers are
called that because they use
echolocation in order to see their
surroundings in the hotel Jill brings up
how the majority of the infected died
quite quickly but those that are
sustained go on living for decades this
is very much the case in the clickers
with them being infected that have been
around for decades and thus the fungus
have managed to take over most of their
body and transform them into these
monsters I love the way that the quarter
steps are located in the mouth here and
it hints at them slowly taking over the
inside but we can't tell until the
infection is further down line baby Rana
has a cup of tea and she learns that
things started a flower and grain
Factory now the reason why I think
chicato was chosen is because it
actually has the biggest flower Mill in
the entire world the bagasari flour mill
ranks as the largest on the planet in
terms of size and scale and thus this is
likely why they picked here anyway she
refers to it as being the perfect
substrate and in biology this is a term
used to describe the surface in which
fungus lives cheers Google enzymes can
also be found here that cause chemical
processes and this may be how the virus
mutated to infect humans now when it
comes to how the fungus spread the game
mentions how it got enough food and a
flower and yeast Factory would be the
perfect place for this to happen when we
look back at episode 1 there was
actually a lot of food that will contain
this ingredient that the characters in
the show actually manage to avoid we had
moments where the younger Mrs Adler made
some cookies and Sarah didn't eat these
because they had raisins in them I was
thinking we'd make some cookies
chocolate chip reason
Mr Adler could also be seen feeding the
elderly Mrs Adler and this could be
where the infection started out at one
offered some food Joel also said But I'm
on Atkins
which in case you don't know is a low
carb diet meaning that things that have
a lot of flour and yeast in are
completely avoided now in the morning
Tommy was gutted that they weren't
having pancakes because Joel and Sarah
had bacon and eggs again they're
avoiding flower products and they also
didn't even have a birthday cake either
so the entire day was them just dodging
bullet I don't know if Joe well not her
now I don't know if Joe would have
completely sorry
I don't know if gel would have
completely skipped I'm sorry I don't
know if Joe would have completely
skipped out on bread when food was
sparse but hey at least they kept that
consistent he says the woman bit three
other co-workers and that they were all
executed but that they don't know who
bit her and thus the virus is still out
there 14 other workers are missing as
well and there's not really any way to
put a lid on this even if they lock down
the country the cordyceps have mutated
now and it's only so long before someone
stumbles into them when they're out in
the wild she says that the whole city
has to be destroyed and we see how this
strategy was adopted worldwide due the
craters later on in the game I I always
just assumed they were collapsed part of
the streets due to lack of Maintenance
but you should never assume because it
makes her oh so are you and me anyway
there's no hope and she wants to spend
the remaining hours that she has left
with her family it's a really Bleak way
to intro the episode and we know that
the following 20 years will likely hell
on Earth due to how far the virus spread
it turned the infected against everyone
around them and even her going back to
her family is something that you'll
likely not experience again now Ellie
very much represents the Hub work here
and this is shown symbolically with a
sleeping under a literal ray of light
that shines down on her gel and tests
sit in the dark or as she's anointed
almost like it's a painting of Jesus or
something a butterfly flies over here
and imagery of these have appeared
throughout the series so far butterflies
actually carry their own meaning and
typically they're used to represent
rebirth transformation and a change in a
positive direction Ali of course could
be this and she has the potential to
cure humanity and take us back to the
way things were where everyone was nice
in the YouTube comments section when you
use were all nice anyway she's again
wearing the same t-shirt that she had on
last week and if you missed that then we
thought it was put on together not to
Young Nathan Drake in Uncharted 3. not
pulling that out of thin air yeah it has
a reason and naughty dog made both
Uncharted and also The Last of Us games
nothing but net now they're still pretty
skeptical over whether she's immune or
not and Ellie ends up having to go to
the toilet she's tossed a magazine and
in the game she ended up coming across
some beauty posters which she was
completely stunned by
a girl is so skinny
I thought you had plenty of food in your
time
we did some just chose not to eat it
this happened just before the hotel
which we ended up visiting in the game
though it appeared way later on the
entire scene takes place in a beauty
salon which completely juxtaposing the
idea of beauty against the devastation
that the world's now in we see Joel's
hands trembling which he diagnoses as a
hairline fracture after beating the crap
out of the guy last week and trembling
are of course a sign of infection and
it's something that test later has so
you can see why she questions it here
when she returns they end up eating and
Jill and Tess eats some crap bars I
think they're called crap bars while
Stelly has a delicious chicken sandwich
this was given to her by Marlene and it
hints to how important she is since
they're willing to give a what would be
top of the range food in the Apocalypse
Now tying back to the whole bread thing
it is possible that Ellie was given this
because she's immuno cordyceps and
therefore there's no risk of her getting
infected Joel and Tess have to eat those
crap bars because who knows what's in
the crops though that might be me going
too far interestingly though there was a
live case in France had happened in the
50s that could have inspired this I've
done a full in-depth breakdown on this
in our video about how the infection
started which is up on the channel now
now just for the cliff notes though
there was some ergot that ended up in
bread and this caused severe food
poisoning and hallucinations there was a
man who thought he was an airplane and
he ended up jumping off a two-story
balcony in episode 1 the sign is said
that there could be LSD like
hallucinations given and this could tie
back to that now a child also attempted
to strangle their own mother showing how
it could affect someone's rage all in
all 250 people were affected by it and
50 of these were condemned to an asylum
it's a really interesting story and like
I say I've done a longer video on it but
the important thing to take from it is
no carbs till mobs but I'm on Atkins
also I was talking about this episode
with Ryan Airy bloody ryanairy and he
spotted at the first line in the entry
as I apologize about your lunch it
brings it all together and adds to the
food theme but also for primary
um shut the [__] up Ryan Airy Ellie says
they're trying to get her to an outpost
out west and there's gonna be doctors
there who can help work on a cure Joel
really doesn't believe this at all and
we'll talk in our spoiler section at the
end how this setup what's to come Tess
just wants to finish the job but she's
starting to gain faith in Ellie and we
can see her coming around if Ellie is
indeed able to help with a cure then
that would make her one of the most
important people that have ever lived
but it just so happens that she's been
slotted up with some let's say Marley
gray characters gel shifts a cabinet Out
The Way of the door and often you drop
these other ones when escaping in order
to stop people or the infected coming
after you speaking of the infected I was
sure I heard the sound effect of a
clicker when they open up the door
also if you're enjoying the breakdowns
please click on that thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for deep
Dives on the show every week we'll be
doing loads of videos on the series for
newbies and also hardcore fans alike so
you definitely don't want to miss out
thanks now speaking of the game they
actually skip over a big section with
the two skyscrapers I was a bit good
that we didn't get to this bit as it's
such a major part of the game early on
they also finished last week's episode
by showing a shot of it to tease what
was to come and it's one of the most
memorable part of the game for me so I
was a bit glad to see it cut now as we
see from the skyscrapers they'd probably
be impossible to climb and descent in
real life due to the angle at the rat in
the game he climbed at one and descended
down the other during the night and this
was all done to escape the federal Camp
as you made your way through you came
across fresh bodies and also encountered
the clickers for the first time after
seeing one grown into a wall this is
something that was teased out last week
and one leaps out at you as you open a
door and you have to navigate past them
as you make your way through the
structure share I'm guessing that they
just wanted to have the one big clicker
scene for the episode and due to the
budget they probably thought that the
museum later on would be the best place
to do it this too is a location that
features in the game as well with a
civil war display being a major part
that we'll get into now in the game you
have to climb scaffolding and due to one
of the skyscrapers being at an angle
they do some really cool stuff with the
physics eventually you make your way
through a train station and what's one
of the tensest parts of the game before
you finally Escape downtown which is
where you swarmed by the infected this
is an awesome scene and they almost grab
you from behind the shutter and I had to
hand it to them I love this moment now
in the show they go the longer scenic
route and Ellie tours the city for the
first time looking at the bombing and
what the Government tried to do in order
to stop the spread
they hit most of the big cities like
this they had to slow the spread somehow
so what happened here they bombed the
hell out of the surrounding areas to the
quarantine zones hoping to kill as much
of the infected
along the way she walks past the stuffed
giraffe toy and these actually appeared
throughout the game at several points
they showed up in Sarah's room on the
ground and you'd often find them just
lying about the place they foreshadow a
big thing coming down the line and we'll
talk about it in that super spoiler
section section section exclusive spoons
I hear they make their way alongside a
highway littered with cars and I
absolutely love the look yeah really
recaptures the game turning this into an
urban jungle where Nature has taken over
once more Ali brings up how she got bit
and this happened in a mall inside the
qz this all took place in the Left
Behind DLC and Ellie says that she was
just in there alone which again super
spoiler section at the end we'll also be
discussing some of the infected that she
talks about here and I'm guessing that
this is all setting up what's coming
down the line anyway after hearing the
Cry of the infected they decide to head
into the hotel in the show this happens
much earlier than it does in the game
where they're not appearing until the
Pittsburgh chapter it really managed to
recapture the look of it though with a
central stairwell and flooding being
present in the game you made your way
behind the reception desk and could
catch your Bellboy trolley similar to
what we see in the show there's also a
grand piano that makes an appearance and
it's here that Gerald talks about his
love for coffee Ellie asks if they've
ever stayed in a place like this and
Tess says you ever stay in a place like
this
uh no a little out of our league now
this is a no to the line in the game
when they first enter the hotel
whoa oh fancy
you ever stayed a place like this before
no
no it's too rich for my blood now Ellie
also mentioned such you can't swim and
brought back PTSD flashbacks of all
those wooden pallets floating in the
water
never again
um just so it's out there I can't swim
well I I don't know how to swim
seriously
do you think we have pools in the QC our
Tess is dead at this point in the story
and I think they've included this bit as
a nod to the game and that it's highly
unlikely we'll be returning here again
in the show this kind of sucks as it
also has another big bit with the
infected but you know with the show
changing some bits and adding in others
we might get a payoff similar to that
and they end up ascending which is when
Tess climbs through a gap in order to
unlock a door for them in the game you
grab the ladder and navigated your way
up the building which is where you
encountered some Bandits there were
other things that we ran into which
we'll save for later in case they adapt
it into a later part of the show either
way here they use a time for some
character development with Jill and
Ellie being forced into an awkward
conversation Joel is clearly a close
book at this point and he lies about
where he's from and won't even answer
whether he and Tessa are an item it's
important to bear in mind that at this
point in the story Jill's pretty much
just a shell of his former self and due
to the death of Sarah he refuses to get
attached to anything he knows the pain
that comes from loss and his sole focus
is on just making it through the
day-to-day be because of his past he
also knows that surviving means you have
to do awful things and thus he doesn't
really like to make alliances in case it
comes to a point where it's him or them
standing in the way of tomorrow are you
once more brandishes her knife and this
is a weapon that she uses throughout the
game now out on the hotel balcony the
group look out and they see piles of
infected they're way more overpowered
than what they are in the game and we
learn that they have an almost hide-like
mind due to the fungus connecting them
in the game if you killed a group of
them that was it and you were completely
safe however here even if you kill one
they have the ability to reach out and
call in the Cavalry the fungi work like
a connected brain and from the vast
strains that live underground they're
almost like telephone wires joining up
the locations if one dies somewhere I
can signal the others and thus the
survivors are constantly on the Run
trying to get away in the show killing
an infected person doesn't mean you're
out of danger and I love this added
Dimension to them now this massive pile
of infected could also tine with episode
1. we of course have been with a time
Jump by following a child trying to make
their way to the qz they'd been with a
larger group and it's possible that
these newly infected people here are
where the kid broke off from now they
also use the landscape to very much show
the objective and where you need to head
buddy dog had some incredible level
design and throughout the game you'd
often see where you needed to go
demonstrated by being yellow in Boston
they had the Golden Dawn of the State
Building constantly off in the
background which is something that the
show also does too I've never been a
Boston myself but but I've seen the
golden dome in The Departed and
obviously it's a sign of status in that
movie so so yeah the bit of info there
haven't haven't been in Boston but I've
seen The Departed five stars on
TripAdvisor now realizing they have no
other way around they go to the museum
which is ripped right out of the game in
there there was a wooden beam that fell
blocking a doorway similar what happens
later on when they get trapped the game
had this separating gel from tessinelli
and you had to navigate past clickers in
the infected so you could catch back up
to them in it you run into a civil war
display a which is something that also
appears in the series as well it was
lined with cases that Hobbit all muskets
and rifles which are another thing that
they perfectly bring across to the
series it was also an officer's uniform
and this appears in the lobby as they
step inside the building initially seems
safe because the roots outside of rotten
away but the open door signals that
something else is going on they catch a
staff member grown into the ground
there's also a recently killed soldier
that has been ripped apart Tess is
optimistic that they were attacked
outside and crawled in here to die but
all it does is signal that something
else is in the building now for me
clickers were something that was gonna
make or break this series normally in
zombie stuff you tend to get your
typical grunt zombies and it's rare that
it goes beyond that outside of Resident
Evil and Left 4 Dead one of the big
downsides of The Walking Dead is that
they just kept the zombies and didn't
really Elevate things from there so you
had this repetitive enemy throughout the
click as though they add this new
dimension and playing those encounters
for the first time in a dark room with
headphones on was abs absolutely
terrifying if you sell much has made a
sound then they would spring out of the
darkness and grab you the worst thing is
is that they were one hit kills on high
difficulties even opening your backpack
around them could alert the clickers to
your location and every encounter was as
intense as a camping trip intense now
I'm pleased to say that the show has
managed to recapture the tense
atmosphere of them and I even found
myself sitting in complete silence
because of how nail biting it was as
they get through the door the beams
collapse and even the shape of how it
falls looks like how it is in the game
we see the mannequins and display cases
and these add extra human shapes to the
surroundings really elevating the
paranoia and fear in this scene one
appears behind a glass case and I kind
of got flashes of the T-Rex scene in
Jurassic Park where when they're in the
Jeep and the dinosaurs on the other side
The Click assessed them out and it leads
to a big fight with two whilst Ali
crawls away out and Jill uses sound to
distract them in the game you throw
bottles and Bricks but he tips over a
statue in order to draw one away he's
also able to keep his flashlight on and
in the game absolutely none of the
infected reacted to light because the
fungi just didn't pick up on it Joel
manages to reunite with Ellie but the
clicker senses them after they step on
broken glass you had to be really
careful when navigating around them as
there would often be piles on the floor
that could alert them at any second
anyway they managed to take them down
but we later learned that Tess got bit
during this we're not sure exactly when
this happens but in the game you find
her pushed up against the cabinet and
have to save her which is when I've
always thought that it happens there now
as they step outside and she sits down
we can also catch a blood stain on her
coat this is probably where she got bear
and my guess is that the clicker pulled
back and then dribble the blood from his
bite onto her Ali walks past a plank and
this scene is pulled directly from the
game after escaping the museum they have
to cross one are we getting almost
identical shot to that when she makes
her way across the beam Tess clearly now
she's on borrowed time too and she wants
them to see the positive news in her
surviving the bite rather than Joel's
Doom and Gloom and we get this line
pulled directly from the game
[Music]
is it everything you hoped for was that
everything you hope for
jury's still out
Drew's still out
oh man
she had another view
can't you know that for you
hey let's pick it up
come on let's get the before it's dark
[Music]
a Joe also looks longingly at his watch
this brief glance at it carries a lot of
meaning as it of course reminds him of
Sarah Ali sort of becomes a surrogate
daughter to him and it's almost like he
has a moment remembering his whole life
before it all went to hell this is a
really important scene as the watch of
course broke when Sarah died this was
very much when the World Ended as well
and time stopped the Joel in the exact
same second that his watch broke anyway
they make their way into the building
with Joel Still suspecting Ellie might
not be the real deal she has a bandage
to cover her bite and in the game when
you'd patch yourself up with a Medicare
you could also see bandages like this
over the wounds now after arriving at
the State Building they see a truck full
of dead Firefly soldiers and also I
think it's worth pointing out that Joel
has an assault rifle for this whole
episode whereas in the game I always saw
him as being more of a pistol and
shotgun man but moving on now on the way
to the location you came across a
soldier with a firefly logo on his arm
and he had a no detailing that they were
gonna look after the girl inside they
discovered dead and we learned that one
got bit which led to everyone turning on
each other Tess is in this situation too
and after revealing her bite they let
her handle things on her own terms Joel
is actually a little bit apprehensive
over this and you can see she comes
towards him that he starts to step back
the scenes play out really similarly to
the game with his getting a few lines of
dialogue that marry each other here
[Music]
maybe they are maybe they hit a map or
something to tell us where they were
going I mean one of them's got to have a
map on them right
where was this lab of theirs where did
Marlene say that she was taking you
Ellie she never said she only mentioned
that it was someplace out west uh I
don't know just west
our luck had to run out sooner or later
you run out sooner or later
she's infected
I Was Bitten an hour ago and it's
already worse this is [__] real Joel
[Music]
they do differentiate how a death plays
out in the game and after revealing her
bite we hear Federal soldiers storming
the area test buys them some time to
escape and she stays behind to shoot it
out with them which is when he's
eventually killed here the infected are
alerted with them scrambling from the
area before to swarm the State Building
test tips over some explosive barrels
and also some grenade so that she can
take them all out it's such a tense
scene watching them close in as she
struggles to spark up her ladder due to
it not triggering and her hands
trembling because of the infection Ted
has then given the kiss of death and she
drops the light air taking them all out
knowing the game at this point you
descended into the subway station which
is where the Federer followed you until
you run into some Infected they decided
to cut their losses and leave and it led
to you going further into the
underground here though I actually like
the impact and the time that they give
to Tess's death he didn't really get a
moment to breathe originally but I just
love the devastation that kind of washes
over this scene Joel as always continues
moving but Ellie stays still hit with a
realization of just how quick things can
change in this world it really is one of
life and death and it speaks about their
characters in the game Ali would even
press Joel to talk about Tess and he'd
refuse to because dwelling on it would
make him face up to what happened it's a
devastating waiter and the episode with
them now on the other side of the
building and that golden dumb hanging
over them in the background now that
takes us into the Super spoiler super
duper trademark greatest of all time
spoiler section exclusive exclusive if
you haven't played both games then duck
out now and also please hit the thumbs
up button on your way out I love you
anyway there's a couple of things in
this episode that link to larger parts
of the game initially when they talk
about how the fireflies are working on a
cure Joel says he's heard this a
thousand times before and he's extremely
skeptical over it and this could be the
show setting up why he does what he does
down the line and Joel eventually gets
Ellie to the fireflies but he learns
that in order to make a cure that Ali
has to die as he turns in a Rambo and
kills all the fireflies and surgeons
before they can operate on her this line
here adds way to him not believing that
it's worth sacrificing her for something
that might not even work and I
appreciate that they added it in in this
scene Joel also refuses to let her have
a gun when she asks this was mirrored in
the game as well and it was only after
the hotel where she saved his life that
he started to begin trusting her now the
draft toy was also a nice little Touch
Too the end of the first game has a
major scene in it in which Joel and Ali
come across him and it shows that though
humanity is doomed there is hope for the
rest of the world Adrian Wildlife has
flourished and it's one of the most
memorable moments in that first game I'm
in the PlayStation classic when they're
in the hotel they get a letter and climb
up which is when they run into Bandits
before making it to An Elevator Shaft
here everything goes to hell and Ellie
and Jola could off from each other which
is when you descend into the basement
into what's one of the most scariest
parts of the game I'm hoping they
haven't skipped over this section as
it's so good and in it Jill basically
navigates through the basement in what's
one of the most tensest scenes of all
time in these dark and Dan Carlos you
run into infected and also blood out
which Ali touched upon earlier in the
episode she asked if rumors about the
ones that threw toxic gas at people were
true and this is a reference to the
giant infected that you run into in the
game the longer someone is infected the
longer they mutate and in the last of us
too you come across the Rat King in the
basement of a hospital this was Ground
Zero for where it all went down and on
the day kicked off they destroyed the
stairwells and ended up locking the
doors thus he'd been down there for
about roughly 25 years it was completely
incredible how messed up he got now they
also have some neat little nods to The
Last of Us Part Two but the Flies went
beyond appearing in episode 1 and we
could also see one on Joel's guitar and
Ellie even got one as a tattoo huge
United ebony Maldonado for pawning at
the shirt lus in the second game is also
the one that Joel's wearing throughout
these episodes now lastly we have
mention of Bill and Frank and in the
game this was the next location where
Joel and Ali went to we discovered that
Frank had left Bill and that he'd made
his way to part of the town that bill
refused to venture to over he did in
order to help Joel and Ellie and they
went on to his school to get a military
truck battery this was in there but they
kept pushing through and eventually
found Frank's Body which is when they
learned that he'd taken it Frank had
been bitten so he'd taken his own life
it was pretty heartbreaking for Belle
even if he didn't show it a judging by
the trailers it looks like they're
changing things for next time and will
of course be back for that so make sure
you stay locked in as for my thoughts on
the episode I think it was handled
really well and these two entries have
been the best video game adaptations
that I've ever seen they nailed a tone
and aesthetic of the game and every
character is really knocking it out of
the park in terms of their delivery and
actions plus the clickers were great too
and I love this track through the
landscape of an overgrown Boston that
was full of danger now I kind of wish
they'd done the skyscruber bit in live
action but I can understand why that
probably wasn't achievable without
completely blowing the budget there's
also the hotel as well which I hope
wasn't the only time that it'll appear
in the series because both these
locations had major moments with the
fact that I think would translate so
well to the show after seeing how they
handle the clickers I was blown away by
it and I hope we get those bits here
fingers crossed we do now obviously I
would love to hear your thoughts on the
show so make sure you comment below and
let me know if you want something else
to watch we've got a video linked on
screen right now and if you're watching
this right after the show then I
appreciate you staying up late with me
and I hope to see you on the next one
you have a great week more Last of Us
stuff coming and also take care of
yourself I'll see you next time peace
questions
[Music]
foreign